[MUSIC].
There's a lot of noise in the landscape
for financial services right now.
We're seeing a confluence of competitive
pressures coming from different places.
How should companies think about
how they can either preserve,
strengthen or build their own competitive
modes in this changing landscape?
FinTech Navigating,
it's evolving competitive and
regulatory landscape is really
about how FinTech's banks and
regulators can systematically think about
the changing competitive environment and
how to design and respond to
Regulations in this changing world.
Be it issues related to big data and
algorithms,
competitive strategy, digital currencies,
crypto currencies and
the payment system, we've brought together
a group of faculty who have thought
conceptually deeply about
the theoretical underpinnings and
roles of these different dimensions
of the financial services industry.
And at the same time have an enormous
amount of business experience,
practical experience, working with
companies to resolve specific problems.
The practitioners,
the participants in these programs, and
the faculty spend an enormously fruitful
week, understanding how to prioritize.
Understanding how to cut
through the noise, and
see what the clear underlying fundamental
issues are, and to begin to frame
solutions to the problems that they're
facing within their own businesses or
in their own challenge in designing
regulation to move the industry forward.
We're going to be drawing broadly upon the
strength of Stanford in terms of its human
capital, but also our style and
location here in terms of
the entrepreneurial spirit.
This diversity of perspectives and human
capital, will all be in the room together,
challenging each other,
appreciating each other's challenges.
Working together to begin to
see how to develop frameworks
that they can take back and share more
broadly within their own companies.
There's such an opportunity
right now to bring
greater clarity to these cross currents of
economic pressures and
changing regulations.
And who are going to be the winners,
who are going to be the losers,
this is a perfect environment to take up
these issues, to challenge ourselves.
And there's just a fantastic group
of faculty stirring it all up.
[MUSIC]